えっと まだ少々時間がございますけど
質問などはございませんでしょうか
あの五戒のうちの三番目の淫らな行為をしないということなんですけど
ちょっとテーマがずれますが
いつもどのくらいのことを言うのか悩むんですけど
今のお話を聞いていると
例えば実際に行動を起こさなくても
頭の中で考えてですね
例えば目の前に現れたですね
綺麗な女性を自分のものにしたいと思っただけで罪になる
それはどうなんでしょうか
うーん まあこれは清浄で書いてるでしょ
それ以外にもいろいろとたくさんあるので
まあとにかくそれは清浄にその通りに書いてます
人妻を欲の目で見ただけでも
あなたはまあ不倫をしたことになりますよと
それからもう一つ 同性愛の話なんですけど
社会によっても今アメリカでね
道徳的にも認められている国もありますよね
それが仏教だと非常に寛大な態度をとっていると思うんですが
やはりそれは根本的に見ると
要するに五戒の三番目のですね
やはり反するものなんでしょうか
それとも道徳に合ってるからいいんでしょうか
道徳には性的なことは関係ないんですけど
それは同性愛だけじゃなくて
例えば異性に関してもですね
社会によっては一妻一夫で家庭を作ることもありますよね
そういうことを  まあ仏教社会では
この男一人は女一人だよという話もないんです
それはどちらでもいいやと
男は何人奥さんもらってもよろしいし
奥さんは何人男もらってもいいんです
しかし しっかりした家庭を作らなくちゃいけないんです
その責任逃れはできないんだと
それから社会は認めてない場合は
これはなりたたない 例えばもう多重結婚は社会は認めてないんですね
それはそうとなると無理なんです
それを認める社会だったら
それは  それは構いません
減ってますかね 仏教だったら売春は成り立ちます
単純な論理で ある女性は自分の体を商売道具にして
それで生計を立てようとする
それでその女性は決まったお金払うならばいいということにする
それだったら女性はいいかもしれないですけど
それ逆に男性の側 その売春ですね
それをやる男性の側はどうなんでしょうか
やっぱりそれはやっぱりまずいことですよ
到底どちらでも平等だからね
正明に引っかからないんですか？八正道の正明に引っかからないんですか？ それは性的なことだから
道徳と関係ないんです
とにかく性欲は人は堕落するんだということはもともとあるんだからね
やりなさいという話じゃなくて
この仏教ではそういうことはとんでもない罪だとは思ってないんです
売春やってる人が来たっても
あ どうぞどうぞと 我々は何のこともなく普通に説法したりはします
それは差別をしないということですよね
職業において  職業には文句は言わない
差別をしないで受け入れるということですよね
軍人はどうなんですか
軍人はダメでしょ  軍人は人を殺すのあれだから
その職業は認めないんですかね
まあブッダの時代でもね
やっぱりあの たくさんの奥さんもらう文化でしたから
しかしもう二人だけの方がものすごいいましたし
すごい金持ちはやっぱりもう何人かもらったりする場合もあったし
それから子孫を作らないといけないんだから,もうもらった奥さんに子供がないと
じゃあ二人をもらいましょうと
仏教の中でもそういう是非事が起きたりしますけど
その時はお互いに話し合って
奥さんと話し合い どうしようか
もう子供がいないこと大変だ
大変でしょうと そうですねとかね
まあそういうことで では誰か見つかりましょうということで
もう一人を連れてくる
夫婦で行って で その場合は不倫にはなりません
もうちゃんと責任持って家の奥さんになるんだからね
はい 基本的に戒律を犯した
罪を犯した だから出て行けという態度をとらないんです
しかし 女性の場合は定義厳しい
女性はいつでも他人に守られているんだ
他人に守られているものは取るなよという法則で決まっているんです
女性は自由になりませんよと
結婚するまでは親に守られているんだ
責任は親にある だから親のものなんです
結婚したら旦那に守られているんだと
だからもう他人のものですから
何か関係持っちゃうと
これでもう戒律を犯ったことになります
それで子供が大きくなったら子供が守っているんだからと
子供に守られているんだということで
なかなかもう隙間がないんです
その定義から  いつも女性っていうのは守られる存在
そういうふうに定義するんですね
現代だとね あんまり  現代になってくると
女性から自分も身を守らないと大変という
だから社会が変わると
その場はね 不倫の定義も変わってきます
守られるっていう教えが
江戸時代は従うっていう風になって
日本人の頭の中にインプットされているから
その反作用で そういう風な概念を否定しようとする働きはあるかもしれない
だから 幼い時は親に従って
結婚したら夫に従って
年老いたら子供に従うっていう風に
江戸時代の道徳で教わったという風に
それでそれに反発するような専業主婦が組み立てられてますから
守られるっていう概念は
それすらも抵抗感があるのかもしれません
結局は法律で守られているでしょ
なんです レイプは罪ですかね
法律で守られるんだから
以上の人権が それであの聖書にもね
あの欲 欲の目でも見ただけでも罪ですよ
あの不倫やるというのはそれは正しくないんです
で あの罪はちゃんとカテゴリーに分けてますから
体でやる行う罪 言葉で行う罪
考え方で行う罪とかね
その中で重いのは考え方で行う罪なんですよ
だから綺麗な女性だな
自分のものにしたいなと思うことは不倫の戒律に入りません
不倫したことになりません
思っただけだからね しかし
九番目の八番目のアビッジャーという罪を犯してます
心の罪を犯してます 異常な欲を抱いたという
抱いてはいけない欲を欲の妄想したんだという
だから気をつけた方がいいやと
それは異常だから異常な行為をする恐れがあります
異常な行為しちゃうと
これは社会的な問題で
その場合の罪は仏教は軽く見るんです
しかし 執行は軽くは見ないんです
例えば若い男は結婚してない男は色々女を見て調べて見て
調べて考えて歩き回ると
これは別に自然の流れで異常ということもちょっと言いづらいんですよ
誰かと結婚しなきゃいけない
あの女 あの女かっこない
じゃあこのこの人いいなとかね
まあそれでそれで調べていくの
それはそれで女の子も同じことでしょうしね
年頃になってくると男の人は気になっちゃうとかね
色々人と喋ってみたりしたりはするね
それはまあ その年のことだからね
そんなに異常っていうところまでは飛ばないんです
それで仏教では随分人はどう思ってもすごい親切な態度で
人々に対して やっぱり心はそんなもんでということで
何するかわからない 好き嫌いっていうのはもう定めてないし
だから人は何を好きになるかっていうことはもう分かったもんじゃないし
しかしそれが正しいってことは取らない
とんでもない変なものに好きになったんですけど
あなたおかしいとかね
社会から出て行けとかね
人間けしからんやとか
そういう差別はもう罪
明らかに 人は誰でも何が好きになるかって
犬ももうあれなんでしたっけ
もうもうきゅうり食べちゃいますから
これはわからない しかし
きゅうり食べちゃって
その犬がそれで病気になって
お腹を壊しちゃってひどい目に遭うんだったら
もう食べさせるわけにはいきません
好きだからという きゅうり食べて別に何もことはないんだからね
それはいいんだけど もしそういう体に悪い体に毒になるものを好きになっちゃうと
好きだからといって ok わけじゃないんですね
だから人は何を好きになるかっていうことは分かりませんだけど
それによって人を差別してはいけない
しかし 好きになったことはやっていいのか悪いのかというのは別な次元で考えなくてはいけないんです
まあそういうことだから
だからまず言うのは まず社会的な道徳を守る
それぐらいは簡単にできる
窃盗はしないとか 嘘はつかないとかね
不倫をしないとかね しかし
頭で見る見る女が好きになっちゃうんだったら
これはもう頭ちょっと病気だから
それはどうしようもない
それも罪は罪なんですけど
あんた罪を犯してるんだよと言って脅しても
それで解決できるものじゃないんですね
だから自分に管理できるのは社会的な道徳のところだけなんですね
心の気持ちはなかなかそう簡単には管理できない
それにはちゃんと瞑想してみなさいと
ちゃんと妄想の管理もしてみなさいと
そうするとそこら辺は解決しますよ
そうすると一番悪い罪ももうそこで解決しちゃうという風な
この厳密にやりやすい順番でと教えてはいるんです
先ほど長老がお話しになったエピソードで
男の経験と女の経験があって
嫌になって出家したと
そうすると いろんな人からどちらのことが可愛いかみたいな
嫌いか 最後に悟りをあらかた悟りを開いた後
同じ質問を受けた時 その長老はなんと答えたって？黙っていたんですか？それとも
いえいえ もう全く関係ないんだと
どちらにも一切執着はもう全然ないんだと
うん だから執着はもともとは苦しみの根源で
そこは無知な行為やと
執着するんですけど 執着
できるのかと 例えば アラビアの油田は私のものだと
私はそれで私のものだと威張ったっても
これは私のものじゃないでしょうに
全て我々執着するものは一つも私のものじゃないんです
だから もし私がアラビアの中東にある油田は私のものだと
私の個人財産だと思っちゃうと
みんな笑うでしょうね
だから執着っていうのは我々のことなんですよ
中東の油田っていうのは私のものでもないし
私の話はいくらも一言も聞くわけでもないし
どれぐらい手紙書いても
どれぐらい電報して電話かけても
全然もう向こうは向こうの勝手でやっている
それで我々もあれにこれに執着するんだけど
そのあれこれというものはそちらの勝手で動いているのであって
私の勝手で動いているわけじゃないんです
子供が妊娠したっても
子供は勝手に妊娠するし
勝手に大きくなるし 勝手に生まれるし
私の気持ちの通りに行くというわけじゃないでしょうに
逆どう見ても赤ちゃんは赤ちゃんの勝手でしょうに
私の子供やと だったら自分好きな時寝させてくださいと
自分好きなとこ起こしてみなさいと
どちらもできんでしょうね
自分の気がいった時はおっぱいあげてくださいと
その生まれた妊娠した時点からのはよくわかってるはずなんですよ
もう私の気持ちで何一つ動かないんだと
それは事実ですね 人間それ否定する
妊娠した時点から自分の体の権利さえも消えてしまう
タバコ吸いたいんだけど吸ってはいけない
酒飲みたいんだけど飲んではいけない
あっちこっち若者と一緒にいろいろ遊び回りたいんだけど
もうこれやってはいけないとかね
それで突然あれは食べたくない
これは食べたくないと出てくるわ
うつわりと言うんですか？偽りですね
え？つわりというひどい病状態にもなるわ
いろんな食べ物はやけに食べたくなるわ
でもいろいろ自分の体も気持ちも全部もうもう自分のものでなくなってるでしょうね
もう自分の体にしたっても
なのに私の子供やと 逆に子供は私の母やというのは合ってますよ
自分でもやりたい放題イジってやっているんだから
女の体格変えることはできないでしょうね
子供にできるんだから
何のことなく体質も性格もなんだかんだかんでも変えちゃう
自分の好きなように 面白いことっていうのは
この男も女もいろいろおしゃれしたりするでしょうに
しかし 自分の子供がこれダサいとかかっこ悪いと言うと
ものすごい気になるんです
それが 全然関係ないんだけど
自分が大人なのに 大人の社会で行動するためにいろいろおしゃれするんですけど
世界で誰に褒めたってもそんな気分ない
子供に褒めてもらっちゃうと
まあすごいこと だから結局はもう自分のものじゃなくて
なんか自分を支配している存在なんですよ
だからこの執着はもともと
もうたとえで考えた方がいいんですよ
中東の石油は全部私のものやと思うぐらいのアホらしくて意味がないんです
アメリカ人と私はアメリカ人だよと言ってみてくれ
逮捕されます それだけのこと
執着も何も成り立つものじゃないんです
だからこの この時点であってという話じゃなくて
もう初めから執着はもうとんでもないおかしいことで
子供が妊娠したら育てる
それだけの話で 育てることと執着することは別々
そこで世の中はもうもう
変なことを考えるんですね
捨てろといいですかと
それで腰抜けの人々はもうもうもう家族を捨てたい
家族の面倒を見たくない
一緒に同居している人の面倒を見たくないとかね
取れるものだけ取って
自分が責任を果たさないで逃げたいというね
そういう人格できてない連中
この話を聞いて いい話です
よく気に入りましたと
そんなこと言ったってもすぐわかりますよ
こちらが心を読めますからね
ありがたくも何も感じないんですね
仏教を褒めてくれたってもね
迷惑だと あんた方は仏教に対して
と私はそういう態度なんです
だからもう子供に教育費をあげないで
そんな執着だから私は子供時代執着捨てましたよと
執着捨てる執着もともとバカバカらしいんだからね
しかし 教育費をあげる義務がなくなったわけじゃないんですよ
女の人は子供を産んだならば
もうこれはもうもう最低歳になるまででも
面倒見る義務があるんですよ
ご飯作ってあげる義務があるんです
執着はないんだからね
赤ちゃん泣いてるでしょう
お腹が空いてる いい 私は全然執着はないんだと
そういう風に理解するんだからね
これは面白いんです これ
逃げられませんよ ブッダの話は事実ですからね
だから たとえ赤ちゃんが元気でいても
執着してはいけないんです
赤ちゃん死んでも執着してはいけないんです
執着あるんだから泣くんであって
悲しくなるんだ 執着さえなければ
別にあ 死んじゃったということで終わっちゃうんです
死んじゃった 死ななかったならば真面目に育てる
歳まで子供が生きれたならば
そこまでは面倒を見る
まあ歳になって二十歳になってまだいるんだったら
では結婚相手でも探してあげるとか
それはいるならばの話で
それで結婚したところで
孫も子供産んじゃうと
あいつらにも何もできんだから
ちょこちょこと手伝いしましょうとかね
それは孫がいるならばの話で
子供は歳で死んじゃったらそれで終わりで
義務から逃げることはできません
だから執着を捨てろと言ってるんです
子供を捨てろとは言ってないんです
だから仏教ではあのー出家する場合は親が賛成しているのかっていうこと
これ大事な項目なんです
条件の中で だから義務から逃げられませんだからね
親に育てられたんだから
そちらはもう義務が生じています
子供には親から逃げることはできません
親に育ててもらったんだから
親が嫌だと言うんだったら
生まれてきたお前が悪い
それだけの話 なんで生まれてきたのかと
今更親が悪いと何言うんでしょうかと
言うことなんです だから親がいいですよと言うと
まぁ親の面倒やら老後の面倒やらね
そういうことは見なくてもいいっていうことなんです
親がダメというならば
もう出家できない 結婚しているならば
もう相手が賛成しないと出家できない
まぁ出家したがる人っていうのは
まぁ赤ちゃんとか小さな子供いる場合は出家してということはあまり思わないんですから
そういうケースはそれ成り立ちませんし
だから子供の賛成なさいということはそんなになりません
成り立ちません 子供が反対しても出家はできる
で 親が反対するとできないんです
赤ちゃんが泣いているのに
私は出家しますと言ったとしても
誰も出家させてあげませんだからね
それで法律に成り立ち
いや法律でないでしょうと
仏教の法律では ということはあり得ません
ということで あの執着は
執着はもともとおかしい
もともともう頭がおかしいんだからね
だからおかしさに理解するためには
あの例え話はいいんです
中東の油田はすべて私の個人財産だよと
まぁ言ってみれば あの漫才やっている女性の方いますね
何さんでしたっけ？そういう漫才の
上沼恵美子さん  で あんな調子で真面目に言ってみたらどうなるのかと
彼女は病気わけじゃなくて
彼女はすごい あの いや